In my video on the circle division problem,
I referenced Euler’s Characteristic Formula,
and here I would like to share a particularly
nice proof of this fact.
It’s very different from the inductive proof
typically given, but I’m not trying to argue
that this is somehow better or easier to understand
than other proofs.
Instead, I chose this topic to illustrate
one example of the incredible notion of duality,
and how it can produce wonderfully elegant
math.
First, let’s go over what the theorem states.
If you draw some dots with some lines between
them, that is, a graph, and if none of the
lines intersect, which is to say you have
a planar graph, and if your drawing is connected,
then Euler’s Formula states that the number
of dots, minus the number of lines, plus the
number of regions these lines cut the plane
into, including that outer region, will always
be 2.
Because Euler was originally talking about
3d polyhedra when he found this formula, which
was only later reframed in terms of planar
graphs, instead of saying “dots”, we say
“vertices”, instead of saying “lines”
we say “edges”, and instead of saying
“regions” we say “faces”, hence we
write Euler’s discovery as V-E+F=2.
Before describing the proof, I need to go
through three pieces of graph theory terminology:
Cycles, spanning trees, and dual graphs.
If you are already familiar with some of these
topics and don’t care to see how I describe
them, feel free to click the appropriate annotation
to skip ahead.
Imagine a tiny creature is sitting on one
of the vertices.
Let’s name him “Randolph”.
If we think of edges as something Randolph
might travel along, from one vertex to the
next, we can sensibly talk about a “path”
as being a sequence of edges that Randolph
could travel along, where we don’t allow
him to back-track on the same edge.
A “cycle” is simply a path that ends on
the same vertex where it begins.
You might be able to guess how cycles will
be important for our purposes, since each
they always enclose a set of faces.
Now imagine Randolph wants access to all other
vertices, but that edges are expensive, so
he’ll only buy access to an edge if it gives
him a path to an untouched vertex.
This frugality will leave him with a set of
edges without any cycles, since the edge finishing
off a cycle would always be unnecessary.
In general a connected graph without cycles
is called a tree, so named because we can
move things around to make it look like a
system of branches, and any tree inside a
graph which touches all vertices is called
a “spanning tree”.
Before defining the “dual graph”, which
runs the risk of being confusing, it’s important
to remember why people actually care about
graphs in the first place.
I was actually lying earlier when I said a
graph is a set of dots and lines, really it’s
a set of anything with any notion of connection,
but we typically represent those things with
dots and those connections with lines.
For instance, Facebook stores an enormous
graph, where vertices are accounts and edges
are friendships.
Although we can use drawings to represent
this graph, the graph itself is the abstract
set of accounts and friendships, distinct
from the drawing.
All sorts of things are undrawn graphs: The
set of english words, considered connected
when they differ by one letter; mathematicians,
considered connected if they’ve written
a paper together; neurons connected by synapses.
Or maybe, for those of us reasoning about
the actual drawing of a graph on the plane,
we can take the set of faces this graph cuts
the plane into, and consider two of them connected
if they share an edge.
In other words, if you can draw a graph in
the plane without intersecting the edges,
you automatically get a second, as of yet
undrawn graph, whose vertices are faces, and
whose edges are...well...edges of the original
graph.
We call this the “dual” of the original
If you want to represent the dual graph with
dots and lines, first put a dot inside each
of the faces.
I personally like to visualize the dot for
the outer region as being a point at infinity,
where you can travel in any direction to get
there.
Next, connect these new dots with new lines
that pass through the centers of each old
line, where lines connected to the point at
infinity can go off the screen in any direction,
as long as it is understood that they all
meet at the same one point.
But keep in mind that this is just a drawing
of the dual graph, just as a representation
of facebook accounts and friendships with
dots and lines is just drawing of the social
graph, the dual graph itself is the collection
of faces and edges.
The reason I stress this point is to emphasize
that edges of the original graph and edges
of the dual graph are not just related, they
are the same thing!
(Or at least, I would argue they should be
thought of that way).
You see, what make the dual graph all kinds
of awesome is the many ways it relates to
the original graph.
For example, cycles in the original graph
correspond to connected components of the
dual graph, and likewise cycles in the dual
graph correspond with connected components
of the original graph.
Now for the cool part.
Suppose our friend Randolph has an alter-ego,
Mortimer, living in the dual graph, traveling
from face to face instead of from vertex to
vertex, passing over edges to do so.
Let’s say Randolph has bought all the edges
of a spanning tree, and that Mortimer is forbidden
from crossing those edges.
It turns out the edges Mortimer has available
to him are guaranteed to form a spanning tree
of the dual graph!
To see why, we only need to check the two
defining properties of spanning trees: They
must give Mortimer access to all faces, and
there can be no cycles.
The reason he still has access to all faces
is that it would take a cycle in Randolph’s
spanning tree to insulate him from a face,
but trees cannot have cycles.
The reason Mortimer cannot traverse a cycle
in the dual graph feel completely symmetric:
If he could, he would separate one set of
Randolph’s vertices from the rest, so the
spanning tree from which he is banned could
not have spanned the whole graph.
So not only does the planar graph have a dual
graph, any spanning tree within that graph
always has a dual spanning tree in the dual
graph.
So here’s the kicker: the number of vertices
in a tree is always one more than the number
edges.
To see this, note that after you start with
the root vertex, each new edge gives exactly
1 new vertex.
Alternatively, within our narrative, you could
think of Randolph as starting with one vertex,
and gaining exactly one more for each edge
that he buys in what will become a spanning
tree.
Since this tree covers all vertices of our
graph, the number of vertices is one more
than the number of edges owned by Randolph.
Moreover, since the remaining edges make up
a spanning tree for Mortimer’s dual graph,
the number of edges he gets is one more than
the number of vertices of the dual graph,
which are the faces cut out by the original
graph.
Putting this together, it means the total
number of edges is 2 more than the number
of vertices plus the number of faces, which
is exactly what Euler’s formula states!